sara is in California welcome to Dave
Ramsey show Sarah hey thanks for taking
my call
sure so I'm 22 and I just started
listening to your radio show on Spotify
and reading the Total Money Makeover
baby step number two okay yes and I have
about $20,000 with a student loan debt
and I have enough money today to pay all
of that off but originally I've been
saving that up to be a full emergency
fund and fund to save or to buy a new
car because my current car is on its
last legs so the thing is my company
that I work for has a program where it
will pay off my student loans but they
pay the minimum monthly payment so it'll
take about seven years for that to be
completely paid off so doing what your
advice would be would you suggest that I
spend all of my savings and become
debt-free
as of today or would you recommend
letting my company pay that for me in
using my funds for my original purposes
if they were gonna do it faster than
seven years I probably would do it but
seven years is a long time your life
your life is gonna change a lot between
20 and 27 years old yeah what do you do
for a living I agree I'm a program
manager at a tech company in Silicon
Valley Oh your life is really gonna
change a lot in seven years I mean
you're gonna be working on things seven
years from now that we're aren't even
invented now right I mean it's the world
you're in is a very high rate of change
what do you make um $80,000 a year
wonderful way to go yeah that's a great
gig that's just great
yeah and you're but you're in a very
high cost of living area obviously yeah
what is your car worth I I don't know I
haven't checked on Kelley Blue Book's
but I would I would estimate around
$3,000 right now maybe what's wrong with
it
it's a 2004 it has over 200,000 miles on
it and it's broken down on us a few
times we put a new engine on in it
it's just give enough problems oh my
parents and I oh I see okay so you put a
new engine in it yeah a couple years
back so it's okay right now but it's
still giving us problems so I'm running
it all the way till it dies that's the
plan orange I have all the money yeah
yeah so exactly how much do you have in
savings exactly I have 21,000 like one
hundred okay and exactly what's your
student loan balance that's a good
question I think it's around 21,000 okay
so you'd have like a hundred dollars
yeah I wouldn't even have my $1,000
emergency fund okay yeah so the way I
answer questions here is have after
having live these principles for 30
years and coached bazillion other people
live these principles for 30 years what
would I do if I woke up in your shoes
and now the reason I tell you that is
because I've got a 30 year head start on
you right
you've been Dave Ramsey and looking at
this stuff for 20 minutes so it's a
little harder for you to come to the
same conclusions I come to but I'm gonna
you know still duty-bound to say what
would I do which is what you were asking
me is what would I do
and so but the wreath you know the
answer is important because there's some
track record behind it so I don't want
you to go below $1,000 balance and so I
would send twenty thousand one hundred
dollars to the student loan and next
month I would pay it the rest of the way
off then once I was debt-free that would
move you to baby step three I would
build my emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses you're gonna do that
in three months
okay so we're four months from today you
have a fully funded emergency fund of
about fifteen thousand dollars and you
have no debt then I'm going to save five
thousand dollars or more as quickly as I
can
five to ten and by car
okay and so what we're saying is by late
spring you're buying a car right okay
and all that time you will have been a
hundred percent debt-free most of that
time you will have had enough money in
your emergency fund that if the car did
completely lay down and buying a car
became an emergency you would use your
emergency fund to buy the car right okay
your risk on having serious car problems
and leaving you in a lurch is only about
three months worth the rest of the time
you're gonna have the money to buy a car
it's just not necessarily exactly the
way you want to do it so you know unless
I miss my guess by summer you're gonna
be in a pretty nice car and you're gonna
be a hundred percent debt-free now how
big is the company you work for massive
and it's about thirteen thousand
employees worldwide okay - too big to
change policies quickly because I
wouldn't be afraid if it was a little
bit smaller to walk into my supervisor
and go hey I need you guys to kick this
student loan thing up a little but
they're not gonna do it who you're
talking about it's not gonna do it I got
an idea who this is okay they're not
gonna change your policy for you there's
thirteen thousand of you so they can't
do that that makes sense all right so
yeah we're because it takes too long for
them to get you out of debt I'm just
gonna go ahead and get out of debt and
here's the other thing
I suspect you see you're 20 22 22 yeah
so I suspect by the time you're 26 that
you're probably going to be making 200 I
hope that's the world you're in if you
keep growing your skillset and you know
you keep your you know you keep your
finger on the pulse of the digital
movement and you keep bringing bringing
and adding value that market is moving
so quickly because I think your personal
growth curve is going to make you worth
a lot more number one but number two I
think the the marketplace is going to
move on
make you worth more hmm so that's what
I'm really not me I mean what I have
seen for instance Ruby on Rails
programmers make that change in the last
decade is astronomical they're making
double what they used to make okay just
just those guys and and you're in a
position in Silicon Valley to really
take advantage of being on a tech curve
right here so yeah you got it made you
you aren't you on the right track Wow
I'm honored to talk to you thanks for
letting me work through your problem
with you that's fun